Thanks to Brilliant for supporting this episode
of Journey to the Microcosmos.
Go to Brilliant.org/microcosmos check out
their Scientific Thinking course and get 20%
off an annual premium subscription.
When you’re in the business
of hunting for microbes,
sometimes you have to send
some weird emails.
That is why James, our master of microscopes,
sat down one day to send his own strange request
to the people at Coralaxy, a coral farm in
Germany.
The job of coral farms like Coralaxy is to
cultivate corals for people to fill their
aquariums with, protecting natural reefs from
collection in the process.
And while farming might make it sound like they’re
growing plants, corals are actually animals
colonies made up of marine invertebrates that form
spectacular structures painted with vibrant colors.
So you can imagine that there are lots of
beautiful things to seek out from coral farms.
But James was not emailing to ask about corals.
James wanted something a little more unusual
and a little less desirable.
He wanted to know if Coralaxy could check
their filter systems and send him some of
the scum that deposits there.
After all, we’ve found fascinating organisms
in fish tanks and in sink drains, why not
combine the two?
Fortunately, the people at Coralaxy were also
very curious about what their reef tanks might
reveal when put under the microscope, so,
of course, they sent James a bunch of stuff.
In addition to corals, which we’ll get
to in a future episode, the generous team
at Coralaxy put together two bags of sediment
and gravel from their tanks, three large bottles
of plankton cultures, some macroalgae, and most
exciting of all to James, a concrete brick.
Yes. You heard me correctly.
It just so happened that this brick had been
placed in many of their tanks.
So when James got his hands on it, he was
delighted to find all sorts of interesting
creatures growing on the brick.
Some of the organisms he found were completely
new to him, like this weird living hybrid
of spikes and puff.
Understandably, when James first saw it, he
wasn’t sure what to make of it.
But then when he zoomed in on those tiny pointy
bits, he could make out the needle-like structures
called spicules that belong to sponges.
Sponges are sort of like corals in that they are
invertebrates that don’t move around.
But they’re also much more simple than corals.
This particular sponge is known either as
a pineapple sponge or a q-tip sponge, both
of which are excellent names.
They’re found in marine waters all around
the world, but they also often hitchhike their
way into aquariums.
James also got the chance to record some ciliates
that he hadn’t recorded before, like the
Peritromus you see here wheeling itself across
the slide.
And from even closer up, you can see those
individual cilia at work as they push the
organism around in circles.
One of the fascinating parts of looking at
organisms that have come from aquariums is
getting to see them make homes out of structures
we don’t usually get to see in our normal pond samples.
Like these worm-like ciliates called trachelocercids,
which are stretching in and out of a shell they found.
There are several of them inside there, turning
the shell into its own little trachelocercid commune.
Which makes you wonder how they all found
the shell to begin with, and how they all
decided to gather there.
And then there’s this ciliate swimming in
the remains of a crustacean’s carapace or
shell, looking just a teeny bit lost.
The structures in the carapace make for a
harsh landscape under the microscope, like
columns of icy rocks that the ciliate has
to make its way through.
From other angles, the landscape shifts into
a surreal crystal palace, one that seems to
have temporarily trapped the ciliate in its
confines.
But the carapaces that now have formed chiseled
boundaries around the ciliate were once part
of a living, breathing animal, a crustacean.
So where did that crustacean go?
Well we don’t know for certain.
But perhaps they got eaten by this flatworm.
You can see the remains of a crustacean taking
up space, static in the otherwise very wiggly
body of the flatworm.
Zoom in closer and you can see the remains
of the crustacean surrounded by a mixture
of yellow and brown that looks like dijon
mustard.
Of course, it’s not like the flatworm has
made a tasty mustard crustacean dish for itself.
Those bits of brown are actually endosymbiotic
dinoflagellates that live inside the flatworm
in exchange for providing nutrients to the
worm.
This relationship mirrors the mutualism that
corals and algae exhibit as well, with corals
providing protection and photosynthesis supplies
to the algae, and the algae providing nutrients
and waste-removal services in return.
Unfortunately, not all creatures are turning
to algae for a mutually beneficial relationship.
Some just like to use algae for food.
Like this ciliate called Chlamydodon, whose
body is filled with its dinoflagellate dinners.
And inside the sediment samples that James
studied were many gorgeous algae-eating foraminifera.
Those hard exteriors are home to amoebas,
which use their false feet to poke out and grab food.
But they’re also an integral part of marine
food webs because animals like fish will come
along and eat them.
In addition to the microbial worlds that James
got to explore in these samples, there were
also plenty of creatures who are, by our standards,
on the large side.
Like this snail spinning around in circles.
We can’t speak to what these snails are
up to, but it’s not surprising to find them
here.
Snails eat debris and plant matter, which
makes them useful living vacuum cleaners to
help clear up aquariums.
Plus, they’re just cool to watch,
this one has an
“alien crawling across the empty night sky”
vibe that makes it hard to look away.
And in addition to the snails, there were
bristle worms in these samples that we were
very excited to see, but we’re going to
save that excitement for the next episode.
For all the things we know in these samples,
there were also some mysteries as well.
For example, we think this creature might
be a flatworm, cause it kind of looks like a flatworm.
It certainly moves like a worm.
But this is the microcosmos we’re talking
about, a place where appearances are often deceptive.
And since we can’t identify the species
we’re looking at, we’re not actually sure
if it is a flatworm.
With higher magnification, you can see these
rod structures inside of it, like a bunch
of tiny little worms nested within the body
of this maybe-worm.
Except we have no idea what those structures
are.
So if any of you know what this creature is
or what those structures are, please let us
know in the comments.
What has stood out to us as we’ve looked
through all of these samples is just how many
different types of creatures there are.
Some resemble life we’ve found in other
bodies of water, and some are things we may
not have gotten a chance to see if James had
not taken the step to send a strange email
to a coral farm.
It should hardly be surprising given that
corals support such an incredible breadth
of life in the wild.
But it is still beautiful to explore that
breadth of life, to see its smallest forms
thriving because to them, even a farm is wild.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us
as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you to Brilliant for sponsoring
this episode.
Brilliant features hands-on, interactive courses
in science, engineering, computer science, and math.
And Brilliant has recently upped the interactivity
in their courses.
In their Scientific Thinking course, you’ll
dive into the world of scientific principles
by exploring the laws of physics and principles
of engineering.
Along the way you’ll gain the understanding
and insight needed to start looking at the
world in a different way.
The courses are designed for people of all
levels, so you can jump in at any point and
work your way to mastery.
And Brilliant courses are also available offline
using their iOS and Android app.
So if you’re traveling or have a spotty
internet connection, you’ll be able to keep learning.
If you’re interested in learning more, you
can get 20% off an annual premium subscription
at Brilliant.org/microcosmos.
The folks whose names you are seeing come
up on the screen right now, you know who they
are.
They are the people who make it possible for
us to send a weird email to a coral farm and
get a bunch of stuff mailed to us so that
we can show you the beautiful diversity of
all that is going on inside of a brick!
What a cool thing we are all doing together.
Thank you so much for your support, and if
you’re interested in that you can check
it out at Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro
If you want to see more from our master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, and why wouldn't you,
you can check out Jam & Germ on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us.
There is always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby.